AJ thanks for joining us how you doing
where are you right now I'm in Orlando
Florida where I grew up and where I live
still to this day and dealing with the
ramifications of older MA that just
won't quit how is it there how are the
conditions
well land is good now we took a pretty
good beating on Monday morning Sunday
night late Sunday night about two
o'clock but a lot of trees down a lot of
people still without power just going
around you know it's amazing what this
hurt these hurricanes Harvey and feel
for the people in Texas and then Emma
here in Florida what it's done to people
to bring them together I mean you just
see people out helping each other it's
nice to see how did you prepare for this
well in Orlando we don't get it as bad
we're pretty fortunate we're in the
middle of the state so we don't get the
surge that all the other people get on
the coast and where they get underwater
so we don't have that but for us to
prepare you just try to trim your trees
as much as possible you stock up on
water you stock up on Chef Boyardee
ravioli and SpaghettiOs for the kids and
just hope and pray for the best and it
doesn't get too bad well we appreciate
you joining us a couple of things to
jump into I don't know if you're a big
fan of streaks whether it's good or bad
and what it means for doing that in
September and how that's gonna play out
and what it means in October so look at
the Dodgers look at the Indians will any
of this have an impact on what their
postseason performance will be well the
Dodgers have a history of not winning in
the postseason so anytime you need 11
games in a row in September it's got to
break your psyche a little bit cuz if
you remember two weeks ago everyone was
talking about them being one of the
greatest teams of all time so now all of
a sudden you lose 11 games in their own
people like what happened to the Dodgers
so you can say as a player it's not
going to affect you but the end of the
day it's gonna affect you because you
can't believe they were supposed to have
this team that was built never to lose
and just keep grinding out wins and you
lose 11 games in a row it knocks you
back a little bit but I promise you this
I'd much rather be the Indians win in 20
games in a row than the Dodgers lose in
11 games in a row
but I look at the Indians and it feels
like nationally there's still not a big
story why is that well it's good they're
in Cleveland I mean if you're if the
Cubs would come back and won 20 games in
a row
imagine the headlines they'd be you know
maybe right up there with the 27 Yankees
and and these teams at one so it's just
because they're Cleveland they're a
little bit smaller market and they also
you know this isn't a knock on their
Flyers Kluber is a great a great great
pitcher probably top three or four and
all of baseball but he doesn't command
attention because if you watch him last
night he throws a CG shutout to win 20
in a row he barely cracked a smile it
was like okay great I threw another
shutout I'm probably going to win the
song now and I don't even want to smile
or celebrate it that's what's awesome
about him and then yeah they have Lindor
and they have Ramirez some guys but they
don't command a lot of attention they're
not they're not a group of guys that is
out there just commanding attention
saying hey look at me everyone look at
me they just go about their business and
I think it comes from Francona and he
does a great job getting them to
understand what what baseball is all
about they do it the right way and they
are they are really fun to watch they
need to hire you bring you in they need
to you know somebody who's gonna hate
somebody on the team no no no they're
doing great you know I post baseball is
hard man it's hard sport to play once
you once you're out of it you look back
and you realize how hard it was to do it
every day it's it's hard but we watch
and we'll see a pitch and we'll go how
did you miss that or to change them the
guy swings a mystery like how did you
swing at that and in your mind you're
like man I did that about a thousand
times so I know exactly what they're
thinking and it's a different
perspective but it's fun because being
in being around it still I still get to
go in I still get to see the guys you
see guys are your friends with and guys
you didn't like too much and you're
respectful and they're respectful back
and it's fun to just be a part of it but
it's also it's fun to remember the
struggles and look back and say man I'm
glad I don't have to try to do that
anymore
do you remember a time and I always
wondered why catchers weren't better
hitters because you guys called pitches
you saw more pitches than anybody can
you explain that why catchers aren't
better hitters in general because they
get the crap you get the crap beat out
of them every game that's one reason
okay your hands beat up you get your
head beat up you get your knees beat up
your feet beat up so that's one and then
also just it's hard as a catcher you
don't get to play every day you're not
outfielder I remember watching
outfielders during our games and the
pitch should be coming this was when I
was on the when I wasn't playing and I'd
watch your outfitter and they're working
on their swing in between his doctor you
know chasing a ball around or thinking
about how am I gonna get Giancarlo
Stanton out on the next pitch so I mean
there's it's just such a mental toll
that it takes on you catching it
sometimes hitting gets pushed back to
the back but I mean if you look at Posey
and some of these other guys that are
going now there's some pretty good
hitting catcher is going he's AJ
Pierzynski Fox Sports baseball analyst
joining a Stan Patrick show Red Sox and
the Yankees and stealing signs and now
electronics involved in this how how
often did you guys steal signs or did
you feel like somebody was stealing
signs from you when you played you
always were aware of it I remember we
had a time in Toronto where Rick Hawn
who's a GM now the White Sox was the
assistant GM and he went out there we
had a we were almost a hundred percent
sure that the Blue Jays were stealing
signs and we went out there and I don't
know that the White Sox ever admit this
but we caught a guy with a camera out
there with looking at the Hall of the
catcher sign so we started mixing them
up and one of our pitchers turned around
backwards to the game and the SkyDome
had nobody in it there was a guy in a
white jacket out there and he would
stand up on fast balls and sit down and
off he called every pitch he called
every pitch not looking at the game from
this one guy and so we were like okay we
got to do something about this so we
started mixing it up every inning
changing signs and it was amazing how
much they're hitting and that series
went down after the first game once we
figured that out but I mean it happens
I've never heard of using an Apple watch
to do it it's kind of an ingenious if
you think about it maybe when I was a
red sock if they would have gave that to
me I would had a little better run there
but I don't know I mean they were just
doing it seemed like to relay the
science from second which I get but if
you're if you watch enough so if you
watch enough signs from the videotape
before the game you can pretty much
figure it out if I'm a catcher I can
watch a game you give me you give me
three pitches I can figure out what
signs are using from second base most of
the time would you want to know what
pitch was going to be thrown to you I
only wanted to know if a guy had a pitch
that was really really nasty like if a
guy had a split finger that just I knew
I couldn't hit then I would just not
swing at it because I'm like okay you're
coming to split let's not swing at it if
he throws three in a row because most
the time those pitches are balls and the
problem I ran into when I knew what was
coming a lot of times I'd be like oh
there comes a curveball and they throw
and it bounced in the grass in front of
home plate and I'd swing at it because I
knew a curveball was coming so I just
have to tell myself just don't swing
when's the time that you felt your most
helpless and I know that you're gonna
you know be self-deprecating here but it
was their time when you just stood in
the box and you go this isn't I don't
even know what I'm doing here that you
were that over there was a couple of
pitchers well first of all the one guy
that I always hated facing more than
anybody was a guy you might have heard
of named Mariano Rivera cuz he he had
one pitch he knew it was coming and
being a left-handed hitter I couldn't
hit it he just break that side go up
there and literally and be like alright
he was bad on my breaking day and I'd
ask the guys on my team on your back I
hope you don't like this one because
it's gonna be broken again so he was the
one guy that I was like okay I know
what's coming there's no way for me to
hit this ball hard and keep it fair and
plus every seemed like every time I
faced and the umpire gave him like a
three foot strike zone on each side up
and down and I was like oh man and he
deserved it but I still a little
frustrating but why do we give great
pitchers even more latitude no they're
great they don't need it they've earned
it though they've earned did I
understand I mean remember back when
Greg Maddux and Glavine were at their
prime and their home balls a foot off
the plate and Hobbie
Javy Lopez and any Perez were setting up
a foot off the plate they were all
strikes that was great especially being
a Braves fan it was awesome hey well
good luck with what's going on
poster man there in Orlando always great
to catch up with you we appreciate it AJ
AJ Pierzynski Fox Sports baseball
analyst the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience